all right guys
bang bang got jessie here thanks so much
for doing this man
pleasure to be here thanks for having me
for sure so let's just get started with
uh your background what uh where'd you
grow up what'd you do
before you got into a crypto yeah
absolutely so i'm a washingtonian grew
up here
uh born in new york but grew up in
washington uh
i've been lifelong entrepreneurs so i
started the lemonade stand when i was a
kid
when i was 13 i started a web
development company and
kind of morphed that into what
ultimately became a hosting company
so this is sort of before cloud
computing existed you had to run servers
to run websites and i
was that was my business 2003
uh started a company called blue box
which
ultimately became a cloud computing
company raised about 22 million
adventure and sold that company to ibm
in june of 2015. it's a great exit for
the investors for
our team it was pretty exciting like we
thought we were going to be a pretty
influential part of the ibm cloud
ecosystem and spent about a year and a
half
trying to integrate that product as an
ib as a distinguished engineer
into the broader landscape and and
quickly sort of realized i was pushing a
boulder up a hill every day and having
it roll back down on me every night so
uh at that point um wanting to do
something inside ibm like i
i have a lot of respect for ibm as a
company they've been around for an
incredibly long time they've survived
all kinds of technological change felt
like i wanted to be able to try to
actually help
and so i found a world ibm ventures and
they were at the time trying to launch a
blockchain focused accelerator
and so i helped them with the design of
that and so my job over 2017 was
effectively to research
the crypto space become sort of the
subject matter expert which couldn't
have been there could have been a better
time
to have that be your your focus and it's
a space i've been familiar with for
quite some time nick carey from
blockchain.com and aaron voorhees from
shapeshift we all went to college
together in the same
like business class so i've watched over
their shoulders over the last couple
years since they built
their businesses in this space and was
fascinated but
it takes a lot of intellectual bandwidth
to actually dive in and understand
what's happening here and
didn't really have that until 17. so
spent
a number of months there and was
instantly hooked
yeah and so like as you're starting to
do that research
just like where do you start i think a
lot of people
didn't know anything about whether it's
bitcoin crypto uh blockchain
whatever kind of part of the industry uh
but
they come at it from the retail
perspective right is hey i go and i
probably heard about
price movement or uh something like that
and i start researching
when you're coming at it from uh one ibm
and then two is trying to actually
create an
accelerator like where does that
research begin and maybe walk us through
like what did that process actually look
like
yeah i i really wanted to just
understand what the landscape looked
like
like what were the companies what were
all the pieces and that's the hardest
part
i think for anybody getting started here
because there's so much
in this space so obviously started with
bitcoin trying to understand
what the sort of the fundamental
technology discovery was there that made
bitcoin
um and the blockchain underneath it sort
of a distinct and unique
technology and then from there sort of
branched out into the broader ecosystem
2017 was such a just absurd year in
terms of
number of projects number of uh of icos
number of new technologies and so
i ultimately might became a sponge it's
like any and all information i could get
blood uh podcast blogs twitter telegram
reddit
like everything i could find and i i
would just absorb
on the accelerator side i think it was
an interesting question like so many
corporate accelerators are designed
really to just sell
sell that company's products so like
microsoft has microsoft accelerator
and the objective there is to sell
startups azure cloud
that didn't seem like a super
interesting or compelling
initiative to me what i wanted to do was
build goodwill in the startup community
for ibm and then in turn sort of have
that benefits
uh benefit ibm down the road and i
thought ibm was in a unique position
because they have
all of the customers that these startups
want they're already ibm customers
and so but these startups don't have
time to go out and that
excuse me that the enterprise customers
don't have time to go out and vet
startups so we thought there could be
this really unique opportunity to match
make between startups and ibm's
customers
and to go and figure out what problems
those enterprise customers were having
and find the startups that help solve
them so that was sort of the
the design for what we wanted to do and
to try to
bring bring all that research together
plus
sort of vet and discover all of these
these ibm
customer problems that felt like an
interesting product
fortunately the the program in q3 of 17
there was no fun date like the funding
got cut
and so we never actually got to launch
it
but it was fun like either way we got to
do the research which was was
phenomenal for sure and so eventually
you
decide you're going to go and launch a
fund what was that thought process and
kind of what was the impetus for
uh going on the fun side rather than
building another company
yeah it's a good question so q3 of 17
ibm comes back and says there's no money
to launch this accelerator they offered
me a role working on on hyperledger
which is their private blockchain
product
the time that just didn't seem like an
interesting uh initiative for me i i was
more excited with kind of what was
happening on the finance side
of this space and so
i sort of concluded that i was going to
leave and started to kind of look at
what else was out there in the space
it's a q4 of 17 everything was on fire
like
the everything was just bananas and the
exchange space seemed really interesting
to me
and so i i went and reached out to
coinbase into bittrex and
a number of those folks about taking a
product management role
but they could barely i mean they were
we could barely keep the platforms
online let alone
um hire or do interviews like it was so
wild to think back at how
fast everything was moving and so
started
to look at the space and form some
conclusions
around applicability of algorithmic
trading which i thought was a unique way
to approach
this space in particular so this was
from all the research i would
had completed over the summer started to
notice a few patterns like this is a
space where
there's real liquidity like money is
flowing in and out every day
but it's fractured across all these
exchanges globally right there's no
single place you can go and
and have visibility into all the order
books or all of the
the volume repairs that are trading it's
it's all over the place
uh the other thing that i found was
really compelling is that
all of the data is is publicly available
and
data can mean a lot of things right you
have all of the data that exists on
chains
all the movements of capital and within
the ecosystem that's all public
but you also have all of the trading
data so if i want to go to the nasdaq
and say i would like a copy of every
trade that occurs on nasdaq
i will pay out the nodes to get access
to that data
and there's sort of a walled garden as a
function of that it's really hard to
to participate in that ecosystem but in
crypto
every exchange streams all of their
their data for free
so every time somebody buys or sells
that match is publicly available and i
can collect it
and i can analyze it and so it felt like
there was an opportunity
to build a set of software that
collected all that data
normalized it into a consistent format
because every exchange has its own
nuanced data structures and then analyze
it and look look for patterns
and we've all sort of done this thing
you stare at these charts long enough
and you can visually see patterns in the
charts
and so if you can visually see patterns
you can programmatically see them and so
it started to tinker kind of nights and
weekends at the end of
q4 to see if i could come up with a set
of software that would do exactly that
and by the end of the year i think it
was actually three days after bitcoin's
all-time high
in december had something that felt like
was working and reached out to sadie
rainey my co-founder and said i've got
this interesting idea
i think we should go build a company
around this um and so we did
we we launched strixolithin in january
of 18.
and the interesting thing here was
really kind of looking at the broader
landscape and
and the tooling that's available in the
broader landscape
i had thought kind of coming from the
outside that there would be
providers software tools etc that would
solve
many of the problems you would need to
launch an investment manager
think simple things like accounting
tools trade execution tools portfolio
management risk management like all of
these pieces that you need to
effectively run a fund vehicle felt like
that would exist in the ecosystem
as we started to kind of map everything
out at 18 we realized none of that
existed
like there were there were sort of
piecemeal tools here or there
but but none of it was there in a kind
of end-to-end
complete way and so that felt like the
first big hurdle
we had to go build all of that to
effectively operate
and so in uh in march we
raised some equity capital and from
outside investors to to build that
software platform
and spent much of 2018 kind of getting
that
the groundwork built uh
and so first question's got to be where
does the name come from right
strix leviathan which uh i've had to
pronounce over and over again so that i
can now pronounce it
uh where does that name come from that's
not like a normal name that comes out of
the hat it seems
yeah it's there's definitely some
meaning behind it too so
strix is sort of an owl of the night and
leviathan is a sea monster sort of
octopus type creature and so
we thought about what we were trying to
build with this business this is an
industry that never stops right
everything trades 24 by seven
and so the owl to us represented uh
something that's always watching always
listening so keeping an eye on on what's
happening in the market
and then an octopus is obviously a sort
of a multi-technical
big-brained incredibly intelligent
creature so we wanted to kind of bring
the symbolism of
always paying attention and being able
to multitask and respond with
intelligence
to the market and do so in a way that
that
kind of causes people to ask the
question like everything in this space
has block this or
chain that or and it's all the same
names and
we didn't want to kind of follow suit we
wanted to say oh what what does the
strix leviathan mean why did you pick
the name got it i love it and
what exactly is the thesis or strategy
today
yeah great questions so cryptocurrency
is a speculative
asset class in our eyes there's
fundamental value in this market but
it's not shared amongst market
participants
so the reasons you believe bitcoin are
valuable are not the same reasons that
other people believe bitcoin are
valuable
and we see that with models like stock
to flow or or
the habit analysis that exists like
everybody has their own opinion
so in in our eyes that lends itself to
really being able to trade these in a
systematic trade is markets in a
systematic way
so we take all of the data we get off of
all these exchanges
we run it through a whole different set
of filters and algorithms and we look
for patterns and trends
and we move the fund long and short
based on what those those patterns and
trends say so it's an actively managed
fund
based on the patterns that exist in the
data
got it and so how does that uh kind of
change over time as you see
uh times of very high volatility and
then times of
uh almost no volatility right if you i
would argue over the last couple of
weeks there's been
uh very little volatility and then
obviously we saw earlier this year
literally in one day the price dropped
50 percent and then we saw
a massive rally uh off the bottom and so
kind of talk us through
um how this type of strategy interacts
with those different environments
and kind of the evolution through a
trading year if you will
yeah i love to vote but i there's a
saying in boating where it's like
hours of boredom followed by moments of
sheer terror and that's
absolutely what trading crypto is like
so i think a lot of
a lot of the work we've done and i think
a lot of the challenges people face is
that they look at this space
under the lens of time like so they'll
say oh in the last day
bitcoin has done this and i'll make my
trading decisions based on that in the
last hour the last four hours
these these different things have
happened and that doesn't really work
for exactly the reason you're talking
about because
in the course of 15 minutes like over
mother's day weekend over the course of
an hour the price fell at 15 20 percent
and so what what we've done is spent a
lot of time looking at capital flows how
does money actually
move through these markets and we've
designed a set of technology that allows
us to say
in a given day we expect this this many
uh periods of evaluation to occur but in
in a period like march 12th
where you saw that 50 drop we may target
12 candles in a day but a day like march
12th we may have printed 80 candles
based on the amount of volume and
capital that changed hands so our
objective is how do we elongate those
periods of chaos
and be able to make decisions based on
what's happening there and how do we
sort of
shorten the period of lobo and i think
it works really well in these markets
because by far these are these are
trending markets over time
and the reflexive markets meaning as the
price begins to move it typically
continues to move
and it does that more often than not so
we do really well
in periods of time where that trending
behavior exists
and periods like the last six weeks
where the
markets really have been low vol they've
been range bounded very choppy
that's where we struggle but but our
belief is sort of over the long term our
ability to kind of play those
those very big movements and benefit
from those very big movements
um outweighs and and allows us to
outperform in a broader sense
the rest of the market got it and i
guess part of this too is you guys are
obviously able to capture a lot of data
and do that analysis but then you've got
to actually execute the trades
um and do so i'm assuming in in a pretty
accurate
uh high frequency way if if you so need
that
maybe talk a little bit about the
infrastructure that exists
uh you know kind of outside of you guys
and then what you've had to build
internally
uh to be able to execute such a
data-driven strategy like this
yeah this is one of the biggest
surprises that i
witnessed coming into this space so we
started off very early 18 trading
everything on exchange
and because everything is fractured the
liquidity on each individual exchange
is pretty slim like you can't move
significant amounts of money without
experiencing pretty high execution costs
or slippage
so that wasn't going to work for us so
in 2018 we pivoted from
trading on exchange to pivoting via what
they call otc
so these are other companies that
effectively aggregate liquidity across
multiple exchanges for you and they'll
provide you a fixed price
and and you can you can trade that way
so that those otc providers in 2018
everything was done over skype
like that was the formal way to do it
you got a skype chat room
and you said i want to buy a half a
million dollars of bitcoin or i want to
buy a million dollars of bitcoin
and they gave you a price and then you
went in three other chat rooms with
three other otc desks and you all
asked for the same thing everybody's
giving you different prices and they're
validating their prices kind of as
as the market's moving i get blew my
mind that that was
the accepted status quo and hundreds of
millions or billions of dollars move
through the markets that way and so we
that was how we traded for the first
six or seven months and then finally
towards the end of 18 into the beginning
of 19 we started to see
a number of these providers begin to
have apis so that meant
that we could electronically connect our
system
into their system and get quotes without
having to interact
with people in in chat but we only there
was only one or two and it's sort of in
in our business you never really want to
have one or two counterparties you want
to have a diverse set of people you can
trade with
so we thought about hey maybe we'll
build the chat bot that'll let go and
talk to these people and like do the
trading over skype through it through a
chatbot and that
just didn't it felt clunky so we finally
just sort of waited and eventually we
got
some four or five different
counterparties that all had had these
apis
and now all of our electronic our
execution beginning electronically so
when we say we want to go buy
quarter million dollars with the bitcoin
the system pulls up all these streaming
prices
and then the trader on our team click a
button and instantly lock in a
price and it's nice because it gives us
we know we're getting best execution
across all these different providers we
can see all the prices in real time we
can see exactly what the sort of the
cost to execute is
and it also tells us a lot about what's
happening in in the market how those
prices
uh are relative to to what the spot
price is
in in the market at any given time but
the answering thing so like that's the
that's the spot size like being able to
buy and sell coin
the lending side is still done all over
it's now moved to telegram
right right but if we want to borrow
something we're back into telegraming
like we need to borrow a million dollars
of the bitcoin and like negotiating
these rates and everything through
uh through chat and so it's just it's a
funny state of
affairs with with where we are you've
seen companies like tagomi
that launched under the the premise of
trying to fix that problem
uh but but they never really like we
never got a full sort of
true prime brokerage experience with
apis like that never
finally got launched so it's just the
state of affairs is
it's uh it's a funny place this industry
is still so early
so help me understand like what are the
missing functionalities
uh or features that you would expect to
see
in a true crypto prime brokerage that
aren't there today but would
have a significant impact or create an
inflection point for you guys in the way
that you would want to trade
yeah so a lot of this also has to do
with the fact that we are a u.s
company right so many people when they
want to
go long or short they'll go on some of
these international exchanges
that are unregulated in the u.s so call
it like the bit max or
ftx's of the world and they'll they'll
trade there
we're a u.s onshore entity investment
manager so we
we have excluded ourselves from those
venues so
um when we want to short the market we
have to go and borrow coin and then sell
it
and then rebuy it and return the loan so
it's just logistically complicated so
what what we need to see and what this
space needs to see is a prime broker
that allows for spot trading so being
able to buy and sell
a traditional coin and that allows
for shorting the markets being able to
facilitate all the the borrowing
uh that you need to do to short the
market all within one platform
and provide all of that with apis so
that it can be done electronically
and it's missing like i think a lot of
that has to do with the regulatory
work that's required as uh to serve u.s
customers like i think it's just
that there's too much there's too much
regulation today
in the us that makes it cumbersome for
those companies to go through the effort
not knowing if they're actually going to
materially see
business show up and once they they've
gone through all that compliance work
so like the pieces are starting to be
there and you're seeing companies kind
of begin to focus on it certainly prime
brokerage has been the hot topic
over the last 60 days in this space
you've seen a number of acquisitions
um or announcements between coinbase and
bitco and genesis um all sort of
focusing on that area but there's still
a lot of work to
happen yeah it's really interesting too
because it feels like
uh people know that this stuff needs to
exist it's just everyone's looking
around the room like hey who's gonna
build it
uh and some of that is time right and
some of it is uh
the large companies will eventually add
some of that right you see coinbase kind
of acquire
to gomi um and kind of full disclosure
we were an investor there but then you
also see
a lot of kind of building in house large
companies um
especially the international ones you
mentioned but do you think that uh
the funds in the space can ultimately
get their heads around
trusting new startups or kind of
challengers in the space
so you know somebody shows up uh they
raise a couple million bucks and they
say hey look
uh we've built x y or z uh functionality
that you just described
but they don't come with uh the
insurance or the big brand name
or the you know couple years of track
record or history
like what does that look like from a
trust standpoint with funds that are
managing
you know millions if not hundreds of
millions of dollars yeah
it's also it's also a liquidity problem
so you've got all the issues you
described and then you've got the
liquidity problem so
anybody that's actively trading in this
space they're going to go to where the
liquidity resides and so that the
startups that exist and we've seen this
like
exchanges in 2019 that was the hottest
thing and there were new exchanges all
the time
they all had different features and
functions that
that they felt were going to really
differentiate themselves but none of
them had liquidity
liquidity begets liquidity like people
go where where they can trade
and so so that's a big challenge i i
think
part of me has been wondering about this
for the last couple months like i'm more
concerned about where the customers are
like the tagumi piece is a fascinating
one to me because you had a pretty
killer
team and they raised 27 million dollars
in funding
at a pretty high valuation and like they
built the product itself
was good again kind of lacking some of
that the liquidity
and lacking some of the lending side but
like structurally the product was was
pretty good
but at the end of the day i i don't
think that they saw
enough revenue being walking through the
door from from customers to sort of be
able to go raise that next
round and that's that's part of the
problem like you look at this space
2017 2018 2019 a lot of great teams
raised a lot of money at very high
valuations
and that forces sort of the next
valuation the x-rays to be
to be really high and you've got to have
revenue to support that and i don't i
don't know
if the revenue is here yet for that many
companies to be able to support the next
round so
2020 2021 to me will be pretty
fascinating
i think you're going to see sort of the
cream rise to the top
and companies like blockpie who have
been able to to do phenomenal things
with the capital they've raised and
really grow
customers like drive revenue like those
types of companies are going to do very
well
but people who have sort of built either
copycat businesses or things that don't
really
differentiate in a meaningful way i
think you're gonna have a really hard
time kind of continuing to
fund their business what happens there
do they die or is there just
consolidation from like an m a front
i think we're going to see both right i
think that the really good teams and i
think tagoma is a great example right
there's a good team good
product you build you bring that inside
of somebody else that has the
the legs to support it and to help that
grow
i think you'll see that type of
acquisition play out
i mean it really it it reminds me of the
cloud computing space
when i was there with the last business
like the the teams that raised too much
money
they got bought and incorporated to
companies like red hat and
cisco and and sort of trying to help
steer direction inside of those bigger
companies
i think you're going to see the same
thing here and so companies like
fidelity who are building their own
things internally like that's going to
be great
then the sort of the tier 2 banks are
going to realize okay we're late
we're late and we don't have time to go
build how do we go pick up the teams
that know what they're doing
how do we pick up the companies that
that have built functional
products and and kind of fill the voids
that we have internally
and so this this bill versus buy
question
i think is going to play out in a
material way it's just it's just a
matter of what sort of at what point
does this become
such a critical need at each one of
these institutions that
that they realize they're late yeah
it's absolutely fascinating and i guess
part of this
i know you've got a lot of thoughts
around like the power of narratives and
so one of the narratives that you're
um talking about here is in 2017
you know everyone's got their eye on
kind of the the horizon but the horizon
is at like
a 45 degree angle or higher and
everything's going up and it seems like
the world's amazing
and so people go out and they raise you
know tens of millions hundreds of
millions of dollars in some cases we saw
people raise billions of dollars
uh at very high valuations that
obviously puts a lot of pressure on
on people to one deliver but also to
when the market then
doesn't kind of go up forever uh there's
the economic pressure as well
what are some of the other narratives
that you guys have paid attention to
um and you think are either important
for people to uh to be aware of
or two you think are actually driving
some of the movements in the markets
whether it's the
kind of liquid market for crypto or the
uh the private markets
yeah narratives are really fascinating
to me and i think
everybody always wants to have a story
for why the price moved
right and in an industry where where
there is sort of that lack of shared
fundamental value
and the price moves in our eyes because
because it's reflexive it started to
move and people kept buying it and the
way it went
and then after the fact people come and
they put the narrative
on and so like 2019 or 2020
this feels like it's been three years
2020 has been a fascinating year and
you've seen multiple occurrences of
these i mean we started off
sort of at the beginning of the year
with this notion of the having that was
scheduled for may
uh and how that was going to have
significant impact on on price
we saw uh and we saw a lot of price
action
positive price action in sort of q1 and
we saw a correlation with uh
sort of the arraign of the missile
strikes uh
in the middle east we saw correlation
with
um late last year in 2019 correlation
with
uh what they call it the z pumps uh
in in china sort of positive news in
china producing pretty material movement
in price but this is all happening sort
of
after the fact you're putting a
narrative on on a price movement that
happened
after it's happened the interesting
thing in my eyes is that because
crypto it's there are so many retail
traders here
and these narratives can sort of take on
sort of a
power of their own and help move price
around whether or not they're true or
not
and one of those right now that's pretty
popular is this notion of the stock to
flow model
uh stock to flow model is a a
model like a fundamental valuation model
for bitcoin that effectively
uh puts the the price of bitcoin at the
end of the year
above 50 grand uh per coin and so it
gets people really excited
right everybody's like yes like i i
believe in this technology the price is
going to go up because the model says
it's going to go up
and and so it creates this this really
interesting challenge and stock to flow
is an interesting one because the actual
if you look at the theoretical uh math
under underlying the model or the theory
itself
like it doesn't actually stand up to to
analysis but it's exciting
and so people share it because it's
exciting and it gets everybody uh
fired up it's it's getting people kind
of participating in the space
and so these narratives like in our eyes
we try to strip all of that out like we
think
uh those those aren't effective ways to
trade this space
you know it's funny like travis or
mickey guy was listening to that show
that you guys recorded and he was
talking about when they started there
was this qualitative fund like trying to
do analysis and pick these these big
macro pieces
and that's a big challenge because
they're unpredictable like you you only
know that that narrative powered
the the situation after the fact and
then when they switch to kind of this
quantitative systematic approach
things went really well like we we
absolutely agree with that
so these narratives become really
meaningful
after they've become you like after
they're useless like they're just
they're good for they're good for
articles they're good for stories
they're good for
sitting around the campfire and telling
why why
things happen but they don't they
alright they really hold predictive
power
yeah you mentioned uh some critiques of
the stock to flow model and kind of how
it doesn't hold up to analysis
unpack that a little bit more because i
think a lot of people uh they kind of
hear
one side of the story um again because
of the price and the excitement and all
of that like
what is the other side there yeah so
it's it's
this is a really complicated one because
you're you are taking a mathematical
model
that's already hard to understand and
you're trying to dissect it and explain
it in a way that people can get
i think that the easiest way to explain
the summaries
is to think about all of those
statistical analysis that you can go
find
that are that are sort of joke analysis
right so you can look at divorce rates
compared to purchases of margarine in
maine
and you can see that as purchases of
margarine have increased so have divorce
rates and so
margarine must lead to divorce like
there are unrelated variables and
looking at them
you could obviously say that that's not
accurate and
but the statistics hold true and there's
there's sort of high fit to the model
a lot of what we see is dr flow sort of
fits that reality
so the the first big issue is that
there's
a bunch of analysis using so the idea is
with stock to flow that scarcity is what
drives value
that and and gold is used as the example
that
the amount of new gold sort of produced
every year as a function of all of the
gold that is in existence
is so small that you can't really impact
uh
you can't flood the market and thus uh
sort of gold
keeps its value and the argument is made
that the bitcoin is similar that with
the known emission schedule
uh sort of the the flow the new coins
that are mined and minted onto the
network
with every block that that
now at this point is predictable and is
small
and thus we can use that to drive value
and the reality is that the gold
when you look at it both in real and in
in nominal terms so flight should
adjust it or or not and the actual sort
of stock to flow market cap value so you
take this number
the stock to flow number and you develop
a
market us dollar market cap calculation
from it it's had an eight trillion
dollar range over the last 110 years
so it's not sort of this this cleaning
number uh that you can do a statistical
analysis on
an inflation adjusted i think it's had a
six and a half trillion dollar range
so like in theory if you're saying gold
behaves this way
and so bitcoin should well gold doesn't
behave that way
so like there's our first problem and so
like
at a very high level when we develop a
model we have a theory
and if the theory is wrong it doesn't
matter what the rest of the model says
that the theory that underpins it isn't
correct we're now back to this weird
statistical anomaly
uh with margarine and divorce so that's
kind of problem number one and then when
you sort of dive into the rest
of the model that there's other issues
around
sort of projecting future price using a
linear regression
we've done a big blog post about it and
i could get you the link
we try to really explain it in simple
terms
but but again the challenges people
become very religious about the model
we we believe that this asset class is
valuable we think that this
that bitcoin will rise in price and we
it's why we're here right we all
participate in this this because we
think there's some distinctive
characteristic about this asset that
sets it apart from everything else and
we want to participate in
in in that we want to be outside the
sort of the realm of the traditional
financial system
but we don't want people to get involved
in this asset class for the wrong
reasons we don't want them to sort of
follow a model blindly that says
bitcoin's going to be worth 50 000
at the end of the year without sort of
understanding the risks that participate
in this asset class has
and that's that's our problem with that
piece that it feels like a marketing
piece designed to attract new capital
into the space
versus a true sort of fundamental
valuation model
uh that that has predictive power
so you mentioned earlier that um you
guys watch capital flows
uh you've kind of articulated why the
stock to flow model isn't one that
necessarily you put a lot of weight on
what are the other signals or models
that you guys do spend time looking on
and looking at and also believe uh kind
of carry more weight
yeah i mean this is sort of the secret
sauce behind everything that we built
um and it's you know the challenging
thing is that there is no one magical
model
that predicts price right things change
all the time this is a
dynamic moving industry and and signal
that may work for certain periods of
time doesn't work for
during other periods of time so our
objective using this
this software platform that we call
octopus was to build what we call an
algorithm factory
like how do you go from that idea
to testing to validation to production
as quickly as possible if you look at
sort of
renaissance technology like one of the
best performing hedge funds in the
history of the world they don't have a
single
model that they use the single signal
that they use they have
thousands of these signals that are just
looking for little itty bitty
discrepancies
in the market um and that's that's our
objective like how do you find each
individual little thing because you're
always eventually going to be wrong
right at some point the signal you found
will no longer be valid
and so making sure that you you are
constantly cycling through and
identifying new discoveries
that's that's the key uh and to this
this octopus platform being able to to
kind of interweave all of these
different strategies became really
important for us
the other interesting thing and this is
kind of what blows my mind about this
space
like most fund managers in crypto are
managing
their entire portfolio in a spreadsheet
i i don't know how i don't know how they
do it right there's so many little knobs
and
and variables you could turn and so you
think about like a broader
a broader fund you first you pick like
what coins are we going to trade how
many signals per coin
what's the allocation that are we going
to have for each signal that fires like
how do we
how do we determine how much capital we
put behind everything like there's so
many little knobs and levers and
and dials that can be turned uh like
this
the spreadsheet manager like it it
scares me
and so to have have that all kind of
built into software
uh that's been a big focus for us
and we think it's a pretty big
differentiator will you guys ever
uh take that software and sell it to
other people like would you ever kind of
productize it or is it just for internal
use only
yeah i mean this goes back it's the
previous question that i had like are
there
customers there to actually pay for it
um
you know there's hundreds of funds in
crypto i think they'll
call it 500 plus those that are sort of
they're established with meaningful aum
that
technically have the ability to pay so
most of the funds in this space are sort
of in the
the five to twenty million dollar range
right at five to twenty million dollars
on a fund
you're basically covering your you break
even on operational costs
and so you're not going to go look to to
spend a bunch of money on
on software and which is why you end up
with a spreadsheet
uh once you're above that sort of the
guys that are the 50 to 250 million
dollar range and there's
there's not a lot of them but they've
already got their tools and technologies
like that's already entrenched
and there's not a lot of incentive to
switch right the switching cost is high
and so you're trying to effectively
capture people that are that are
new entrants to the space but again they
don't have a um so it's it's really it's
this chicken or the egg problem
i mean in our eyes i i think there's a
bunch of other businesses that that
software
could power um things like prime
brokerage
things like pooled liquidity and there's
there's pieces of what we've built that
are valuable in different ways
so we're sort of doing some work now
thinking through through that piece
but also i mean if that's our
differentiation we sort of we keep it to
ourselves
to some extent it's one one way to
really be unique in this space
yeah i love that one of the last things
i want to talk about
is this idea of comparing crypto to
frontier markets and obviously frontier
technologies are all the cool shiny sexy
things
um that people get excited about uh
crypto
kind of fits in there sort of but also
kind of doesn't when people think of
frontier markets like
how do you guys think about the overlap
between those two
really are what end up being marketing
terms or kind of descriptive terms
trying to describe various technologies
and markets yeah
frontier markets are an interesting one
for us and we think there's a lot of
parallels to some extent i think
what are the challenges in frontier
multiple challenges exist in frontier
markets and
you know you have limited liquidity
or unpredictable liquidity in in these
assets you have a lot of fraud and theft
you have corruption um graph like
there's
there's all kinds of of issues that
exist there and we see a lot of that in
in this space i think that's one of the
challenging things about crypto that
turns a lot of people off initially is
that
there have been so many scams there have
been so many bad actors here
that it becomes pretty difficult to kind
of cut through
the noise and figure out like nobody
wants to be the sucker in the room
nobody wants to be the the guy holding
the last bag
nobody wants to have their money stolen
and i think that's that's a scary
proposition with this space
and it's a scary proposition with the
frontier markets and so
one of the things that that we feel is
really important and that i think a lot
of companies have been working on is
bringing legitimacy to the space
like how do we how do we be more
transparent
as an industry how do we promote uh how
do we have less memes and we have more
sort of serious conversation like how do
we
how do we grow up a little bit in a way
that begins to attract a different type
of investor
and it's sort of the same issue with
frontier markets how do you solve those
liquidity problems
how do you sift through all of the the
corruption and graft and theft
so those those parallels kind of map
well so for us
for from our eyes transparency has been
one of the most important things like we
look for counterparties we work with
that are transparent we try to be
transparent
one of the things we built this year is
this whole investor portal that allows
anybody to log in and view all of their
all of their history and you know we see
countless funds
that have been shut down by the sec in
the last year because they were stray
ponzi schemes
like and it and they raised lots of
money right it's
it's shocking and that they're able to
pull that money in and as an industry we
need to
we need to we need to help stop that we
need to
identify those those companies when we
see them we need to to call out that the
obvious frauds
and and do more to promote this this
narrative that this is a serious
industry that has
lasting meaningful value and is and is
different and
that's it's a challenge it's not an easy
thing to do
uh particularly in in a space where
where theft and risk of loss is so easy
sure what's the one thing that you've
learned or your biggest takeaway
uh since you left ibm and kind of went
on this journey
yeah i i mean it's the classic
entrepreneurial challenge right i think
i went into this thinking this is this
is gonna be
so easy and i think it's it's gonna it
was like this naturally like oh second
business like i know all these mistakes
that i've already made
i won't make those same mistakes it's
like absolutely true i just made
different ones
uh so like any startup
it's just a tarp and it's it's this
it's this game of grit uh in this game
of survival
and and uh for me what was was
fascinating here like the technology
side
i understand learning i'm learning a
whole new world on the finance side
and that's part of the interesting piece
it's like keeping your brain engaged and
learning something new i think as an
entrepreneur that's
that's the name of the game you do this
because you're a non-stop learner
but yeah it's just it's startups are
hard and it's every day is a reminder
that uh
that you can have the highest of highs
the lowest the lows all in the same day
can you share what uh what is the
biggest mistake you've made that you're
comfortable sharing
oh yeah that's a good question uh
you know i think it's it's been a focus
issue i think you know
in 2018 for example
we we had the opportunity to go build
sort of a
side like a market making endeavor
and it seemed really interesting and it
seemed lucrative but it sort of took the
eye off the ball
of some of the other portions of our
business and
it was a distraction ultimately and and
so
like that's the you know startup and
particularly an early stage startup
where you've got small teams
like focus is such a key element of what
makes you survive what makes you
successful
and it's it's easy to forget that uh
particularly when things are moving as
quickly as they do in this space so
at the end of the day it's pick pick the
things that you can be really good at
that you can be differentiated in and
focus on those and and
nail them and then once you've once
you've sort of once you've accomplished
that then you can start to go look at
the ancillary pieces but
that focus is so key yeah i love that
answer
uh before we wrap up i always ask
everyone the same questions
uh the first being what is the most
important book that you've ever read
the most important book i've ever read i
would say it's probably the hard things
about hard things
the horowitz book particularly as for an
entrepreneur right i think
everybody that that has started a
company goes to this period of time
where things are really hard and they
feel
so alone and nobody ever really talks
about
how hard these things are and
that book i was having in the last
company i mean the last company is a
story in its own right we were we were
near bankrupt two or three times in the
history of the company
like after we raised venture financing
right so i bootstrapped the thing for
nine years
um and then within the course of 24
months
we're near bankrupt twice and we pulled
it out of the hat and sold ibm so like
that's a success story
but it was incredibly hard so in the
midst of one of those darkest moments
they're being able to pick up this book
and and hear
one of now the sort of the most famous
entrepreneurs
went through all the same stuff and that
he's human that you're human that these
emotions and the challenges are real
like that was sort of a turning point
that that you're not alone
as an entrepreneur so from from sort of
being able to continue to have that grit
uh and desire to survive like that was
really important
i love that answer what um what do you
think will happen to the bitcoin price
you mentioned that uh it's really hard
to predict but you ultimately think it
will go up anything that you can share
kind of in terms of the medium to
long-term view that you guys hold
yeah i mean we don't make price
predictions that's the beauty of this
business
uh and and why like i wanted to take the
emotion
out of it from from day one i thought
they were there
it is more painful to lose money that's
the challenge of the space right you
have a space where 80
drawdowns are not uncharacteristic and
it's uh
like it's ten times more painful to lose
money than it is to gain sort of
the same amount of money so being able
to sort of take that decision-making
ability
away from a human um and put it in the
hands of an algorithm
felt like a great way to sort of solve
that that problem
i think in in the near term i think
there are a lot of challenges this this
industry
is will experience i think that the
having
which have we've got sort of a sample
size of two prior havings
to to work from and two prior havings
where
the mining industry was so fundamentally
different we didn't have
industrialized mining on the way on the
scale we do today during
either of the prior havings and
you know i think at the end of the day
this is all an experiment and so
we've got a we've got a lot to figure
out over the next
six to nine months like can the mining
industry actually
make profit in this in this
uh sort of new era so i think
there's a lot of interesting pressure
there in the short run and in the long
run i mean we're in this really bizarre
macroeconomic environment where the the
fed is
i mean like stocks trade like crypto all
coins did in 2017 right now
there is no grounding in reality into
what's happening in the traditional
financial market
and and so at some point
that has to come back down to earth um
and capital is going to get
redistributed
and i think because bitcoin is this
thing that sits outside
the digital finance realm i think it is
well positioned uh
to take some of that that capital but uh
but who knows again we're we're this
massive experiment it's
in our eyes sort of being able to play
both sides
both sides of that being prepared for
for both equations
really important for sure uh
last question i have for you and then
you get to ask me one uh it's a fun one
which is aliens
believer or non-believer i mean i think
you have to be a believer like we are so
invincibly small like
we're this little tiny dot in this vast
vast space to think that nothing else
exists out there uh i mean like
psychologically that just has to feel
incredibly lonely
uh hey there ha there has to be now the
question is
why would they want to come here like
it's a tire fire right now that
they got to be like whoa whoa like we
don't have anything to do with that
but yeah i mean i think you you have to
have believe that there's more out there
we don't even understand what's on the
bottom of the ocean
uh like we have we have so much more to
explore of our own planet let alone
everything else that's out there
i i could not agree more i could not
agree more i think that uh
you know there's places in the world
where there's literally humans who have
never come in contact with other
groups of people right i mean there's
all kinds of crazy stuff going on just
here
but uh but the aliens probably do exist
what one question you have for me to uh
to finish this thing up
yeah i mean i think you're in a really
interesting position you you talk to
everybody about this industry right and
i think for for so long sort of 2017 was
was the retail era we had this drum beat
for a long time that institutional money
was coming that was going to save the
space
uh but but you're out in the field like
sort of preaching the gospel of this
being a differentiated
asset class like who do you see
being sort of the next interested party
and and why
yeah i i think that the um the cat's out
of the bag
in terms of like what i'll call it the
large asset managers uh and i kind of
look at it from two standpoints one is
uh there's people who have been trading
liquid markets
uh and they seek volatility and
historically
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies have
provided incredible volatility and so
that just naturally
uh they're interested and these are
people who normally you know i joke and
say they don't care what the asset is
right it's just all numbers on a screen
to them they're looking for
numbers that go up and down a lot and
the delta between that up and down is
big like they think they can make money
and so i think that whole crowd uh for
the most part like many of them are
already in
uh and the ones that aren't like hey
there's volatility here and it's
becoming
more legitimate so they're they're kind
of on their way if you will
the the big inflection point though i
think comes from more of the
institutional
asset allocators and so this is the
pensions the endowments the foundations
the
um kind of all of those types of
organizations and in that world uh it's
still mixed
right you've got some people who are uh
very convinced that look there's going
to be something that happens here
there's just too many smart people going
into the space and working on it
um and so i need to kind of position
myself accordingly whether that's give
money to kind of a more traditional
asset manager i've worked with like a
venture capitalist or something like
that and they'll get a little bit of
exposure
in a fund that has all kinds of
different disruptive and innovative
technologies
uh some say hey look i want to go and
actually just buy
the asset myself so how do i buy you
know bitcoin for my fund
um some people want to allocate to
crypto specific managers
uh and then some people just say hey
look like i'm convinced that's gonna be
real
i just don't need to be the first person
through the door right i'm actually cool
kind of being in the middle of the pack
in the middle of the pack's not showing
up for another
you know two to five years and so like
i'm just gonna chill right
i'll do my learning now and kind of let
everyone else go through the door first
and then i'll go
and so i think that when you look at it
like the people in
that seat any one of those four
situations they control a lot of money
right i mean they control literally
trillions and trillions of dollars
um and so naturally you're gonna see
this uh kind of flow of capital uh
on a macro basis come into space but
also i think that you're going to start
to see the melding of the lines or the
graying of the lines so
somebody like square's a perfect example
where historically that's
like a traditional finance company or a
fintech company and so people would look
at that and say hey i want that my
public equity portfolio i want it you
know
uh maybe my venture capitalist it made
an early investment in it whatever
well now all of a sudden they've got a
pretty big bitcoin business right and so
like
does that go in the crypto bucket does
it not right how do you think about that
who
which manager would you expect to have
made an investment in the private
markets would it have been a crypto
business well probably not because they
didn't have crypto right
if you would have expected your fintech
uh venture capitalists to do it
but in the future we actually may start
to see companies that
aren't so black and white right you
actually get a company that you can have
your fintech vc
investing in you could also have um
let's say your crypto investor investing
it and then you might also even maybe
have like a credit manager
who's participating in some form you
know that's not equity based as well and
so
i think that uh that's the conversation
that's happening kind of behind closed
doors at the
uh kind of institutional level it's just
like how do i think about this what
bucket does it go in
and if i am a believer that there's
going to be value created here
like who in my portfolio of managers can
get me that exposure uh and i think the
people who end up uh
kind of being early right doesn't mean
gotta be first but the people who are
early
obviously get most of the returns or
kind of a higher opportunity for returns
because over time will get commoditized
just like every other asset has
just may happen in you know 10 or 20
years yep
yeah it's interesting i saw uh was it
that there was a
gigantic pension fund that was down 11
in q1
and we start to think about those types
of returns like that's not
and they'll probably have made it all
back in q2 basically the markets have
played out but they'll be up
they'll be up in the first half of the
year right
but uh yes beginning to think about like
okay if if the traditional markets have
lost
sort of all all grounding like maybe we
can begin to look at other things as
well
it's a fascinating question for sure
jesse listen i really appreciate you
taking so much time to do this
where uh where can we send people uh to
find you or strix la
leviathan on uh on the internet yeah
absolutely so you can learn more
to about the strix business at strix s t
r i
x fund f u n d dot com
um i'm on twitter at jesse proudman just
my name
awesome man listen i really appreciate
you doing this uh
you are on the the cutting edge of uh
actually true
quantitative trading um and investing
and i think that more and more people
will uh will eventually realize that
removing the emotion
uh out of the markets and out of the
decision making ends up uh
being quite a uh quite a time-tested
strategy if you will
that's what we think we'll see how it
plays out
we'll we'll do this again thanks for
taking the time appreciate it
thank you